аронів чаю в умовах а то поговоримо з
підлогою полянському заступнику міністру
світою наукою України цього span та павла
вже паша харчування виходять з прав не
патріоті у тієї акронісу що світи буду
заміні ось ці фактично почали засоби
key 1 рубля la comanda табачника я думаю
ще піди і станемо руку на етапі вирішимо по
нею в катар і підтверджуючого направили
ший інший правдивішим капелюхів нових ованеса
швидко і приклад і хто провал вушок
виправлено і тисячі моральної сентенції
і деві мася притягнемо і часто довіряємо а
у школі ще банан їжі з каналу його на
таку дієту з каналами і свято моєї
проблеми возити проблем а літо та
граматики проти якого вінок на
майдані це позиція сьогодні до учасників
кістки українців світити протягнувши в сасш
таки і в цеху умовах форму осіб
випорожнення
храму діани і тут потанин і тільки
підручник ах там ще й на майдані та
ялиця стояв за україну і ялицевий конов
випадкові накази влади ван і почалася
часто задніми тиміш початковим і
програмами зад і миша підр учнями та
часто їх навичка почала і ті самі 4
али вісь уроки ви не взяв і різьблені їм до
сюди програм повернемо вал вулиці та сюжет
рахунок тапір міністерство нироб вчилася
сама чину кулуарно цього ден че 2
чиновники внесла зради
розуміється люди диску тут душа бухло і
води мізерний затишок і важливі в чудовисько думки з
пожувати iv у тому числі бочки в
журналісти у старших вчив там посилені
правильно корпоративно покличте ще
мовляв якова клада тою історію чиниш і
зрадити нас правді на тему очевидно
терпіти їх то пиши програми та
підручнику дуже важливо чудовиськ вкажіть
хто навчається потім і програмами
підручником та
і ми таки зради привнесла в нас
винесені владних ви
you to ви ще хотіли люди процесом та
Головна мета
повернення готовий ще їй історія України
і ми миємо в чат та історії України не
вугілля дають частину знайти з моменту в
історії нашої подоби ціни з у сидом
chinny подоба з валун шукай би buldak про
даний історичний факт ще б у
чверті штапики свої політичні або
партійні випаду лазні я взяв і шов будинку
і автор підручні канави ніс і в них на
старовині to die менше 3 років при рублі
ти і ще хочу сказати це курити та
автори підручнику
та доповіда че програм за депо війни
мотив ахава людський днесь там ще
політичні партії одні змінити ніші
при владі і непотрібно нам від неї
кодів чином у читачі автору нам від дав
обітниця і там у трапа метод ще головний
суддя та вершник цедить її у 4 аскаридоз
каяки виданий з-під рукава нудиться
підручнику оживи будинку всіляких тапочка
власник ви давно винищив вузлів
бажання сьогодні міністри почту підписавши
Нака дивимося за тверді в нову процедуру
в на душі тяжко нам давалося і там ще
ми так само прийшли на гучний формат
мені вигляд модулів святого ще басистів
кабінетах написали нову процедуру я
знову борати підручнику
та активну частину брала всеукраїнською
асоціації від нього видавати елітні ви
розкусив потім експерти та підірвали люди
які цент каплиця ми могли приходити ay
brat і участь сьогодні наріжте ми
поставив esp одягаюсь коробку та нова
процедура польова в тому ще підручнику
які будучи в хресті ти та школах будуть
адже брат і на чиновники міністерства не
noble дружини його давнього ч будь хто
шкірою у 4 кожна з 18 тисяч сил України
там ще ми вже творили репозитарій
електронні версії всіх створ ван їх
підручник у вільному доступі
безкоштовно їх можна завантажувати і я
здається гористого тася
і шкіряні чотири школи with the первістку
чоловіка в інтернет режимі проголосувати
це дуже шива автора та його твори та
позбавлений на представити його до 3 ст brought
by chas в лосів і більше позитивних
видів води буде друг уват осі
еньші також будуть допущені всі там на
моєму палаці хліб і
all це вже буде торгувати і співавтор і
видавати за владний шкіри руку ватою та
пропан його ти впізнала шаблею з dilantin і
мої жадібні люди на жодного чиновника
нижчі особливий вид катроні закладіть
залишково прийняти рішення
ініціатива міністерства у свитій наука та
розум центр мас відеомонітори 2 диво
допомога та бійцям ато
то учасникам євромайдану які стали
стала інвалідом і ви хочете їм допомогти
проклейки когось із а ось аромати
нову почет можна подальшою противницею
ти сповісти людям і типу страшно чи ти
божого більше віри романська позиція ти
хто про кольори при міністерстві та храм
пекельних організацій там ще владна уфа
і тих, і у чиновника такої роботи на травень
олл-іни з видом метал щіток самий акечі
мало поранених зараз піди на майдані та
думки виймаємо було чесно кирки ст
героїчних людей зажадати дали нам
шкіряній та кожному криму та Україні
Загалом у знайду гаю жити та й своє
здоров'я ці люди винні мати
професії завтра
часто мета біля будинку та пивні фофани проц
його обличчя до рослі люди all i типу рани
не відтяжки часто у 3-го не отримала
вже у неї важливі в легких роботу запахом
і тому ми про по ну і мощі б ці люди
виставили свої свідчення яка б сокира
новий фах у нас рядок та їх особливе
втопив фізичних можливо стоїть у не
вистачило б на but i і думки проти нього
з університетами та
prophecy на технічними початковими за
скарбами і ми хочемо допомогти шкірні
людей не як навчання на ніби новий faq
обидва забудьте їж впали фіксацію і у нас
вже е першило ставки люди нас повернулося
до трапар наймаючи його люди на молодого
професію тракториста і буде азарі став
цієї позиції людина молоді провини може
проти ти там уже в нього пішло джина
рука на тому місці vatika адже логістика
керування транспортними за собою та
механізмами і ми за 1 проти мости
мчать битися люди на законних
приставах і змогла турботи та нішу
професію і змогла реалізувати успішно
ділася прощай думаю ще пройде година і
блок дуже неправильно нібито думки коляда
такий великий кікос типу поранених і від
батька та за раз поривів великих місяців
кодексі тур буде про паралельних
шпата лях на мага і mcsim допомогти цеху
олени павино пройти там ще при деррик 2
а ті люди за дружину зможете видно weight of
трач енакін сівки втрачений easier в
вони повели б ти сама дістати нами і ми
повели допомогти
на but цю професію дозвольте ніби і
самодостатніми і сам із реалізованими
Цілісно наша спина побачилися і
граматики та організації та євромайдан
сос та центру злити та монітори нове
адже міністерство святі науці ми кріпи
для тяги в наша коаліція тяпу поведінка
волосся
і я вам скажу тих же nikon їздові поверх
я скажу відра зазівалась від чого мало їж
їх інституті та людей активатори різьбленими
способів матеріально-технологічну
допомогти річка схема для того, щоб
примати на прокладці
другові свято поривалися в когось якщо
це магазин конкретно робота людям зате
заяву
де інформація та на і
про майдан сос і на сайті центру світло не
моніторингу та такої електронної пошти
міністерство почту та науки України
я люди voluntary до 3-ї опікується люди на
виході ніж телефонному режимі на контакті
електронної пошти та чиї вище спосіб для
ваги в ім'я чого ван охочі каменю та його
оточення і, як видно, рубль і пропозиції
the vaccine шива початкового за подачі на
адже процесу що ваня скажу зараз
початку у нас було менше мбіт нитку або
ми з початку подумав ще нам реально
скажемо допомогти у ця рана
російсько-української війни за пораненими
ще б можна його легше води захочуть ви
клада ти предмет за христів і чесних
школах там ще гарний і подачі нам
Микола не дано знайте по темно розширив
його силу мучить чи може хтось хоче
здобути підопічний фах а за раз вона вийшла
і на нижчій спеціальності та правнуки
і технологічні та еньші токто ну проект
вин розростається про важливі геть із зали
були жадібні частки
ось у всіх reach of тому забував вам
детально шкірні людей не покинули
проведені тим шляхом і банани стани
студентам через добуду і лише спосіб
професії б сказала про
російсько-українську провину і так розумію
приватних перевізників буде сни про on
the top у вас точно апараті а про
російсько-українською війною правильно
розміри
скажи я їду з голи всі безпечні в
чиновних і слави ти себе гігантські
і як історика там ще нас правді але
увійшовши проросійську українську провину та
чому такі за слідом насті назва там ще
за звучати так і називається початку і.д.
україна агресор а потім україна яка
обороняється з російсько-українською війною
вони мужеська та ти чого нам же потро
піти до підручника на доступну руку
там ще ніхто з нас сьогодні не може
парити бачати годину і
завершена для мене результат кіса вежах
для українця я очевидним безладно
україна sw у ній прямому
ліцею вина та
і в сочі з подружжя ще хотілося цю
пункту харчування прем'єр арсеній яценюк на
ще давно за протяг на п'яний зрада це
закон про свиту хотілося помилка нкр це
звали просто самі дається
а чому ми прийшли таким капелюх мастики
ебу політичний консенсус та консенсусу
фракції парламенту спочатку прийнятий
новий
проєвропейський закон перевищила почет і
тим часом він був його готовий дати тільки
проектів закону рамка питання виду цю
муть з ще до шкіль але його почти та інших
ним етапі владним можемо і виніс ти його
вже на 1 ударом батько кістки та на
експертний rosewood то владна pisa
підібрати його не і їжа парламенту або
тут живлення також чиїсь вирішимо складі
парламент моя налагодження його розряду ти
ці закони також провини моя головна нам
йти яскравість про святі потанини і пту
мастики руки розпочато в школі хоче тому
трлн ці ключі в народись моя ніби видів
чаю максимально ланцюг живлення програм на
них часто і нарікання та підручнику
тамбова там новий закон проекту
аспектів і розширення повна вашої
початкового закладу алана там нести його
адже паві дальності аж дім вузли його і
матеріальні за треба не вона я червоних
палиця
я думаю ще вже в сасш таки за
результатом та парламентських виборів ми
будемо носа 30 законопроект там ще гвинт
дуже світі вже підготовленої зодіаку
ван плани по вуха за це ладу нас у
студії на вода у нас у студії була у
павла полянської доступний до міністрів
святі наукою україни